starting tomorrow testing for kobe 19 at
texas station is moving indoors over to
cashman center
as our hector mejia reports the new
facility is designed to give everyone
a break from the heat university medical
center in clark county invited us inside
to give you a look so
when patients arrive they'll notice
markers on the ground for social
distancing
off to the right patients will walk up
to a registration table
check in and in the back end of the room
that is where
people will administer the covid19
test and you get to do it yourself
starting tomorrow they will operate
five days a week tuesdays through
saturdays 8 a.m
to 4 p.m and we've learned to have
separate areas for those with symptoms
and those without symptoms
our process is now indoors and climate
controlled
we're friendly comfortable and like i
said convenient
cashman's site will have a walk-up area
for those who do not have appointments
and it'll operate on a first come
first served basis they've made
scheduling an appointment a little
easier all you have to do is head over
to umc's website and make an appointment
there
reporting from cashman center hector
mejia 8 news now